préparer mon sac à dos ou chargeur si
j'arrive à charger mon téléphone j'ai
pris de l'eau j'ai pris des pâtes et
prix des des fruits et c'est tout j'ai
ma valise qui est fait si jamais
l'ambassade me dit qu'ils vont les
évacuer cette vidéo nous a été envoyé
par ce Français vivant à Kiev ce matin
terre et dans son appartement
horrible et ça c'est amplifié vers 4h 5h
du matin depuis sa fenêtre il nous
montre la rue désert
pour échapper aux frappe russe CESU
craignait en trouver refuge dans cette
station de métro cette nuit
sur les visages
la fatigue
et l'angoisse
des familles des enfants
installés sur des matelas ou à même le
sol
je suis ici parce que je pense que c'est
l'un des seuls endroits en ce moment où
vous pouvez vous cacher à Kiev
tous les autres endroits sont
terrifiants
je me sens surtout fatigué et anxieux
c'est tellement inhabituel
rien de tout cela ne me semble réel
je ne sais même pas quoi penser
se perd tente de calmer son bébé
pendant que dans un autre abri on chante
pour essayer de se rassurer
[Musique]
d'autres ont préféré fuir sur les routes
des embouteillages monstres direction
l'ouest pour quitter le pays par la
Pologne voisine comme pour cette
expatrié français
et tant que partout
des soldats partout des gens qui
sont justement les stations services
sont prises d'assaut laissant c'est
rationné le trajet s'annonce encore long
pour les milliers d'automobiliste
[Musique]
aucune opération d'évacuation n'est pour
le envisager pour les civils